ya sabemos cuáles son los retos que el
presidente el nuevo presidente tendrá
que enfrentar pero cuáles serían los más
urgentes a resolver
bueno el más urgente a resolver
corresponde principalmente al acuerdo
con el fondo monetario internacional que
se negocia en este momento que inició la
negociación
el presidente saliente carlos alvarado
eso será el principal condicionante que
tendrá por ejemplo el poder legislativo
la asamblea legislativa ya que hay que
recordar que durante estos primeros
meses de gobierno el presidente chávez
la agenda de la asamblea legislativa
vendrá dada por el poder ejecutivo por
primera vez en la historia ya que
previamente iniciaba la asamblea
legislativa la agenda al cuando iniciaba
un nuevo gobierno una nueva
administración
este acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional el mismo presidente chávez
ha afirmado que va a renegociar que va a
incluso a proponer metas más ambiciosas
que las propuestas es decir las
propuestas por el presidente saliente
carlos alvarado entonces este desafío
urgente
se
complementa o se contextualiza
principalmente con la frágil situación
económica que maneja el país actualmente
pero también por la urgencia de lograr
un acuerdo con el fondo que es como digo
un condicionante principal que deja la
administración alvarado quesada al
gobierno del presidente rodrigo chats